first of all I think we all understand
the urgent need for more weapons and
more ammunition and more support to
Ukraine and that's been the message from
NATO allies especially when we met all
of them last week at our defense
ministerial meeting NATO allies are not
least the United Kingdom are providing
unprecedented support to Ukraine and now
we're also providing more armor battle
tanks but also Advanced Air Defense
systems
and and also a lot of ammunition and I
think we need to understand it is not
only about providing new systems but
also ensuring that all the systems all
the weapons which are all there get
sufficient ammunition spare parts
maintenance so they can function and
work as they they should we need to
ensure that Ukraine gets the supporting
needs to Prevail and to push back the
the Russian Invaders you know that they
want um jets fighter jets you said
yesterday that NATO allies have never
been more United why is there no
consensus about Jets
what we have seen is that the support we
provide has evolved as the war has
evolved in the beginning it was a
enormously important or the main focus
was on light anti-tank weapons then and
then and then later on artillery a more
long-range fires like the high Mars and
then air defense systems including
Advanced systems and now more The Heavy
Armor uh the the the the challengers
from from the United Kingdom but also
infantry fighting vehicles from many
countries and leopard battle tanks so we
will continue to consult on exactly what
type of additional systems allies will
provide but again we have to remember
that not only discussing what kind of
new systems it is extremely important to
also ensure that all the systems which
are already there get an enormous amount
of ammunition of spare parts and
maintenance to be able to operate as
they should that's perhaps the most
urgent need to to sustain all the
systems which are already in place yeah
I mean surely that's a given though I
mean why send them unless you can back
them up with what's needed
yes but that's a huge task because since
this now is becoming a a war of
attrition a grinding War attrition it
turns into be a battle or Logistics so
we haven't had this kind of uh war in
Europe for since the second world war so
this is about us NATO allies and
partners also ramping up production
because so far we have provided support
by uh digging into our stocks but the
consumption of ammunition in Ukraine is
much higher than our production so this
is not sustainable so the only way to
sustain our support Ukraine is to do
what we have started to do now and that
is to engage with the defense industry
to make sure that allies are signing
long-term contracts I met with foreign
minister coleba in Brussels early this
week and we discussed how we can work us
with that with a Ukrainian defense
industry to ramp up production of basic
things like shells for uh the the
artillery which are which is already in
the in Ukraine so it's a huge task to
sustain with spare parts ammunition
maintenance of all the types of weapons
which are already in place in Ukraine
how far will NATO go to end this war
we will stand by Ukraine for as long as
it takes I met with President Biden and
what we call the B9 leaders as the
leaders of the NATO allies in the
eastern part of the alliance yesterday
in Warsaw and the message from from them
as it is from all NATO allies is that we
cannot allow Putin to win in Ukraine and
that will be a tragedy for ukrainians
but it will also be dangerous for us it
will send a message to President Putin
into other authoritarian leaders that
when they use military force they get
what they want and that will make the
world more dangerous and us more
vulnerable so it's in our NATO allies
security interest to ensure that
President Putin doesn't win in Ukraine
yeah what Ukraine wants is membership of
NATO can they have it
well NATO's position is unchanged uh
Ukraine will become a member of NATO
um but the main focus now is of course
to ensure that Ukraine Prevail as a
servant independent nation in Europe
because without that there's no no issue
of discussing a membership and and we're
also working for a what is a more
long-term efforts with Ukraine to help
to modernize the defense and security
institutions to uh to improve what we
call interoperability with NATO uh armed
forces and and help Ukraine move from
Soviet era
equipment standards doctrines to to
Modern NATO standards this process
always started but of course working
with NATO uh on this to move towards
NATO standards will help them to also
move closer to uh to membership yeah
which we both know that uh that there
can't be a war in a country in order for
them to be members of NATO so that means
November membership of NATO this year
maybe next year maybe not even this
decade what about this century
I will not speculate about when and
again there's a full-fledged war going
on in Ukraine and there's urgent need to
mobilize more support I work on that
every day to ensure that allies are
providing the support of the UK's very
helpful and leading by example but but
we all have to do more and we need to
speed up the delivery of of support so
so that is the main issue uh uh and we
need to ensure that Ukraine prevails to
to be able to address the issue of a
membership uh after the end of the war